not all heroes wear capes
do you not uh i want to i have so many
questions for you well i love you for
that so
you keep loving me for asking questions
do you know i literally had sex to deal
or no deal a couple weeks ago oh my gosh
i was like riding dick and you were like
which case is it going to be it was a
vibe and like you're such a nice did you
wake up with a case right oh the couple
something scratching nothing good
nothing good i mean you were writing
yes absolutely literally and it was it
was just so awesome and i almost think
that the dick riding two dealer no deal
manifested this today like there was
something did you have the guy was it a
guy i know you go both ways yeah i love
that love everyone okay um so so uh
because he could have played me you know
and he could have said open the cage
he's way too away from your thighs poor
for that
who was it
um it was one of my face tattooed
ex-boyfriends
not my bestie's
oh my god no diabolo's one of my best
friends have we had sex maybe
why are you holding back why are you
being
you know what i also found fascinating i
got so many questions and we're not
spending any time on anything but you
were in a very famous throuple grapple
i was indeed in a in a very fellow thorn
yes um she kind of sprung it on me i'll
never not say that like i was i was
dating her and then it was almost just
like a fun way for her to cheat she was
like i have a boyfriend too now like but
it ended up just being really fun like
you know what i mean for a very long
time it wasn't like we were like all
together it was more that we were just
both dating her and like coexisting but
it was monson became one of my best
friends i went on to date him she hated
it it was a notorious big blowout um but
it was a really fun time what's a thrall
a three three people dating
but that's like a couple but
no so that's the difference so a
threesome i kind of understand right a
throuple
is like a a relationship that goes
beyond the threesome yeah like three
people i don't know i mean it was just
fun i don't even know much how long did
the throuple last as a
a coach maybe like a year that's a long
time so you've had a couple of thruffles
no just one trouble it doesn't sound
like it was an ac isn't it throuple
though where everyone's supposed to be
like consent but eventually so are you
mormon
yes
seriously book of mormon just read it
before i came um
no eventually it kind of was a throuple
vibe but in the very beginning it wasn't
but it was dope because mudson was kind
of like my best friend through it like
bella's obviously notoriously very wild
and crazy so it was like mugs and i kind
of found a bond through that you know
like oh my god what's she doing now like
it was just you know it was it was great
but then she was pissed that you guys
got closer yeah so then but she brought
him in
that's what i was saying
um eventually they broke up and then i i
think i was still or known you know her
and i broke up first then
her and him broke up and then we were
both obviously a little frustrated with
bella angry at her so we just kind of
trauma bonded our way into a
relationship and then she was
she was promised
she made a song about me actually called
stupid [ __ ] [ __ ] when i did it and
it was how do you know it was about you
um she hired someone to look like me to
play in the music video she talked is it
a music video yeah they're can we play
it a little bit
i will uh caroline we'll put it up
stupid [ __ ] [ __ ] by bellathorne
is that what it's called how we've been
like none of these things are things you
need to be educated on so i think it's
really funny no i like it stupid [ __ ]
[ __ ] by bella thorne and this is we
have the the music it's it's sfb for
short if it doesn't let this
i've been
are you not working we need to find the
music video though am i not worried what
nbc listens to the podcast and maybe
type in sfb music video
i'm not is it taken down
damn that's down you know i showered
before i got here today just so you know
wow i love that for you i did i do
stuff for a second am i doing something
wrong no i'm just thinking like she said
that she didn't think that you were
anything like this i'm assuming it's
because of your persona on like agt and
stuff but i love that because
but but the thing is that i'm i'm not
doing anything i have never had a
throuple oh
you can have a throuple you should you
would not you can't no i'm not i'm not
saying that you should or can
i'm your dad it's so [ __ ] funny go
ahead i'm not saying that that's right
there we go it's that one okay this is
uh a song when i say wait wait wait let
me
let me just introduce it this next
number is a number by uh bella thorne
it was written about a relationship that
went awry yeah and uh we have the rye
right here in the room yeah i am i am
the rye this is like america's got
talent kind of this is a platinum record
but i'm not over it
she's not over it
she's not over it
she's a super [ __ ] [ __ ]
what part of that song don't you
understand no right is it
[ __ ] or stupid stupid but it's
howie's world and we're just living in
it so whatever he says this is not my
world now you're going to get me in
trouble right this is your world
we're talking he's like i do not claim
she's not saying that you're a stupid
[ __ ] says i'm a stupid [ __ ] and
she's a stupid [ __ ] for liking me also
a stupid [ __ ]
[Music]